Move over, Lannisters – a "House of the Dragon"
scene is taking us back to the ickiest days of
"Game of Thrones." Warning: spoilers ahead
for "House of the Dragon" episode four.
If that scene in the depths of King's
Landing’s underworld grossed you out,
you're not alone — but the actors involved
were apparently just fine with it.
In the fourth episode of this brand new
hit "Game of Thrones" spin-off from HBO,
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen — played in her
youth by Milly Alcock — ends up exploring
the underbelly of King's Landing
with her troublemaking uncle Daemon,
who takes her beyond the walls of the Red
Keep for a stealthy night on the town.
After taking in a crude show about
the Targaryen line of succession
(which paints Rhaenyra in a pretty
unflattering light) and several drinks,
the two abscond to a brothel together,
which... gets pretty weird pretty quickly.
Daemon escorts his niece through the crowded
establishment, taking in scenes of people in
various compromising positions, before assuming
one himself: a passionate kiss with his own niece.
Rhaenyra responds, however, and the two
really start to go at it before Daemon demurs,
apparently in part due to "performance issues,"
which he's dealt with in previous episodes.
This scene may have been pretty
uncomfortable to watch on multiple levels,
but according to Alcock, it was
kind of a breeze to actually film.
Speaking to The New York Post, Alcock said
the scene was surprisingly routine to shoot,
thanks to coordinators behind the scenes as well
as her solid off-screen relationship with Smith,
an industry veteran who's appeared in
everything from "Doctor Who" to "Morbius."
As Alcock told the Post,
"[Smith and I] were just kind of mates. So, it was
quite comfortable. We had an intimacy coordinator,
and we worked with her through the rehearsal
process and blocked it out months before."
That said, there was one major surprise:
the brothel itself. Alcock continued,
"Clare Kilner, our director, made sure that
we hadn't seen any of the brothel stuff until
we were shooting. So, that was our first time
walking through the brothel, and he's guiding
her through the room with all of these other
bodies. So, that was quite shocking. You're like,
'This is kind of weird and silly.' There were
extras who we had just met who were like, 69-ing
for 12 hours. It's pretty gnarly. We felt pretty
overdressed, because everyone else was nude."
"Directing scenes like that can be really
difficult. It's a big responsibility
and it's important to shoot it
from the right point of view."
Clearly, Alcock and Smith were put as at
ease as possible during this tricky scene...
even with the inherent weirdness of their
surroundings during this pivotal moment.
As the predecessor to "House of the Dragon,"
HBO's juggernaut "Game of Thrones" drew plenty
of controversy due to its often brutal depictions
of sexual violence against women — and it seems
that "House of the Dragon" may be taking a
different approach, particularly in Episode
4. When Rhaenyra is left high and dry after her
encounter with Daemon, she returns home only to
seduce Ser Criston Cole, taking complete control
in the encounter and savoring every minute of it.
"House of the Dragon" also shows the other side of
the coin in this episode with Alicent Hightower,
the second wife and queen to Rhaenyra's father
King Viserys. Expected to be available any time
the king requests, Alicent is awoken in the
middle of the night for one of his visits
and is depicted as emotionless and vacant during
the act itself; though it's not a violent scene,
it's an unsettling portrayal of what it looks
like to, as a woman in a medieval era, forego
your personal boundaries and pleasure as part of
a patriarchal structure like an absolute monarchy.
In any case, it does seem like the
actors on set for "House of the
Dragon" are well-protected behind the scenes,
no matter how controversial those scenes are.